[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily r
kelly's secret illegal marriage to
aliyah takes center stage at its sex
crimes trial the singer's former manager
demetrius smith saying he bribed an
official for a fake id when aliyah was
just 15 years old and a major arrest for
the murder of a university of miami
football player brian paddle his whole
world revolved around football and his
family so it sounded like he had a lot
of enemies investigators now saying
brian powder's former teammate shot and
killed him 15 years ago plus weinstein
indicted again in los angeles one of the
sex crime charges thrown out by a judge
is back on the table his former attorney
reacting i look at it as a little bit of
a pylon and you have to wonder if that's
going to backfire and later robert durst
second week on the stand what he had to
say about his murdered best friend's
ability to keep a secret did she know
the truth about his wife kathy's
disappearance all along if
i want to class a crime
i would have had to have committed a
crime
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin r kelly's trial is heating up as
a second woman is testifying against him
accusing the r b singer of assault and
his former manager says r kelly believed
aliyah was pregnant with his baby when
she was 15 years old
demetrius smith said it shouldn't have
happened it was wrong
he's our kelly's former tour manager who
was forced to testify but was given
immunity prosecutors allege that r kelly
bribed an illinois governor official 500
for a fake welfare id so that r kelly
could marry aliyah in 1994. he told the
jury how he helped r kelly get the fake
id while lea was just 15 years old and
thought she was pregnant with kelly's
child a reluctant and sometimes
combative smith told the jury how r
kelly and he rushed from orlando to
chicago for a hotel room wedding near
the airport
also to the stand was jane doe number
five a young woman who says she met r
kelly when she was just 17 years old
jane doe number five says r kelly
pressured her into oral sex when they
first met she admits she told kelly she
was 18 months later she says she was
having such severe abdominal pain r
kelly agreed to schedule a doctor's
appointment for her then she learned she
had herpes according to the woman she
had to live under r kelly's rules in his
presence saying he wanted her to call
him daddy and recorded when they had sex
he's accused of transporting her across
state lines racketeering and forced
labor
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney julie rendellman and terry
austin julie bribery is one of the
charges r kelly is facing but does
demetrius smith admitting to offering to
bribe someone and following through with
it maybe make him guilty and not r kelly
so the answer is yes and no um so we
know that he's guilty he admitted it on
the stand but the one thing he got that
r kelly did not get is immunity
and so the real question is whether or
not r kelly participated in any way with
the plan to have this individual bribe
we know from some of the witness from
from this witness that they believe he
was in the room when the discussions
were had about the bribery but he didn't
make a comment now with that said he
didn't tell them
not to bribe the witness um he he told
them basically that he wanted certain
things to be done and it's unclear
whether or not he actually participated
so yes demetrius uh is the person that
did the actual acts but the question is
whether or not they did it acting in
concert absolutely no terry r kelly made
an album with a 15 year old called age
ain't nothing but a number and even his
manager suspected something was going on
with him and aaliyah does this fit the
prosecution's narrative
you know brian this fits the
prosecution's narrative perfectly we
know that when artists make songs often
times the lyrics mimic their actual life
and here the lyrics said ain't nothing
but a number and throwing down ain't
nothing but a thing so age ain't a
number and throwing down ain't nothing
but a thing to me implies that he is
having sex with younger women and of
course that doesn't mean that that's
evidence or that it'll be necessarily
proving anything to a jury later down
the line but it does look bad and so i
think that the prosecution perfectly
picked this narrative absolutely now
julie jane doe five reiterated some of
the same rules drawn to pace had to
follow but also the same initial lie
about her age the defense is making a
big deal about these lies does that
really matter here though
well it does in terms of the idea of her
credibility it certainly doesn't it
strict liability and it is strict
liability when it comes to you know
child children uh being the victims of
sexual acts however it does make a
difference because if this is someone
that was willing to lie at the time the
argument that the defense is going to
say is well she's willing to lie on the
stand now i'm not sure why it matters
whether or not she was 17 18 or 19 at
the end of the day if he gave her herpes
it sure doesn't matter what age she was
so at the end of the day i don't think
it's going to really make that much of a
difference but yes this is just about
the credibility of this witness all
right we'll see how that jury finds him
credible or not of course the r kelly
trial will continue and will continue to
follow it turning now to more top legal
news a development with one of the
doomsday defendants chad davil is now
waving his right to a speedy trial
lori valo daebel along with her husband
chad dabell are charged with the murder
of lori's two children j.j valo and
tyler ryan lori's case is on hold for
now while she's deemed incompetent to
stand trial but as for chad daybell
prosecutors say the plan is to seek the
death penalty if he's convicted he's
scheduled to stand trial in november now
he's waiving his right to a speedy trial
this means that the november date is
likely to be pushed back chas due back
in court next month
convicted wife killer scott peterson is
expected to appear in court on wednesday
his attorneys say he deserves a new
trial due to potential jury misconduct a
judge is likely to set a date for a
hearing on the matter the juror in
question rochelle niece could be called
to testify the defense says nice did not
disclose that she was a victim of a
crime and that could have impacted
deliberations peterson was sentenced to
death for the murders of his wife lacey
and their unborn son his death sentence
was thrown out now a judge will rule at
a later date if he should get a new
trial too
and in florida a dramatic high-speed
chase across county lines ended on
interstate 95. the martin county
sheriff's office says that vehicle had a
body in it deputies say someone called
9-1-1 on friday night to report a
shooting the caller said they watched a
17-year-old kill someone and then load
the body into a pickup truck and drive
away helicopter video captures the
moments law enforcement caught up to
their suspects driving more than 100
miles per hour deputies use the pit
maneuver to force the driver to stop two
people are now in custody
still ahead on law and crime daily
harvey weinstein is back in court the
latest saga in the former movie
producer's lengthy courtroom drama but
first the arrest 15 years in the making
why police are now pointing the finger
at a former teammate of a murdered star
college football player how the miami
community is reacting next
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live one
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back 15 years after a university
miami football player was murdered
please make an arrest law on crime's
angenette levy is here with more on the
murder of brian patta
brian people in miami florida have
watched this case for the last 15 years
and now finally brian pattas family is
closer to getting some answers
mind you this rocked the community
you're totally rocked south florida's
community at the time and at rock
college football at the time too because
everybody knew who brian paddle was
former miami news anchor tony segreto
covered brian patta's murder in november
2006 the 22 year old university of miami
football player was months away from the
nfl draft when he was shot to death
execution style at his apartment complex
there was no suspect yet there were a
lot of suspects there were you know
there was a there was an incident in a
in a nightclub if i recall where you
know someone said i'm gonna get you one
day and you know there was a very uh
tumultuous relationship with his
girlfriend
all right mr john stand up and face the
wall for me last week sheriff's body
camera video captured the moment patta's
former teammate 35 year old rashawn
jones was arrested for his murder
for us
we always say it's not a sprint it's a
marathon and for us it's about getting
it right the miami-dade state attorney
says an eyewitness picked rashawn jones
out of a lineup and that cell phone
records put jones within two miles of
pata's apartment complex around the time
of the murder the state attorney says
jones told investigators twice that he
was at home that night and that a number
of interviews revealed jones and pata
had ongoing issues including a threat by
jones to shoot pata in the head
patta's family will finally get some
answers
it's been 15 years
of waiting 15 years of missing brian 15
years of waiting for results of being
told constantly to be patient
to have faith in the system to have
faith in the process
and you have faith in us
rashaan jones right now is in jail in
marion county florida that is northwest
of orlando he has not yet been
transferred to miami-dade to answer to
these charges brian
thanks and jeanette let's bring back
criminal defense attorney julie
rendellman and terry austin terry what
do you think is the strongest piece of
evidence that makes police think jones
murdered pata
you know there's no question that the
strongest piece of evidence in my
opinion is the digital evidence the fact
that his first story was i was at home
when this all occurred but the police
traced his phone two miles away and his
home is much further than that so that's
what got the authorities thinking they
did multiple interviews and then from
those interviews they found out that
jones and the victim had a very
tumultuous relationship they had a
physical altercation even at one point
and i think the most damning piece of
evidence other than the fact that
there's this digital trace
is that he threatened to kill para so at
one point there was a threat to shoot
him in the head so all of this together
i think added up to arresting him and i
think that digital evidence was the most
important piece of information
absolutely julie with a suspect so close
to the victim why do you think it took
15 years for an arrest
you know it's funny there's a show
called uh in 48 hours or it you know the
48 and it and it's about the fact that
homicides usually need to be solved
within 48 hours and when they're not
they seem to lose speed and they get
they grow cold very quickly the one
thing about homicides is there's no
statute of limitations and the one thing
that happens is witnesses tend to not
want to come forward and it takes time
to get witnesses especially on a
shooting case like this to come forward
and say what they know and sometimes you
know the passage of time allows them to
feel safe enough and comfortable enough
to come forward we don't know now that
the full details will hear eventually
what the evidence is specifically but
that may be one of the reasons and then
making sure that they've covered all
their bases to guarantee a conviction
even if it takes as it did 15 years
i can see that and jeannette was there
anything else that pointed to tensions
between
pata and jones
well the state attorney said in a press
release that pata was bigger than jones
and that there had been some type of
physical altercation between the two and
that pata had actually beaten jones up
and tony segreto told me that jones
actually was having a relationship with
patta's girlfriend around the time that
this happened so there was definitely
some underlying tension between these
two players who were on the same team
yeah definitely probably expect the
defense attorney to bring that up if
this does get to the point of a trial
that maybe the thrill of self defends
maybe throw a heat of passion we don't
know but of course we'll continue to
follow this case in florida v rashaan
jones thank you all coming up on law on
crime daily alleged lies an affair for
robert durst the latest on his heated
cross examination
plus on then off and up now on again
harvey weinstein is back facing another
charge for an alleged sex crop what this
means for his defense after the break
[Music]
we're back harvey weinstein is again
facing a charges in california
prosecutors in los angeles have obtained
a new indictment for the former movie
mogul after one of his charges was
thrown out
a grand jury has reinstated one count of
sexual battery by restraint against a
woman for harvey weinstein the
allegation dates back to may 2010 the
judge previously threw it out saying the
charge did not properly meet the statue
of limitations guidelines so prosecutors
went back to the grand jury and obtained
a new indictment for the allegation
weinstein is pleading not guilty to all
charges
you know i think that there's really a
strategy question that they should be
asking themselves whether or not they
are staunch believers in the allegation
at some point i think you have to ask
yourself is does this action make me
look as if i'm piling on and you know i
think most people look at harvey and you
know i i of course have have lots of
knowledge and spent a lot of time with
harvey and i just look at it and i think
he is broken um he is clearly diminished
in terms of of health and stature and is
it really going to be beneficial to add
one more count when in the end is it
really going to make a difference
back to discuss as criminal defense
attorney julie renderman and co-host
terry austin terry how is this charge
getting dismissed and reinstated and
back and forth like this can you explain
when you have an indictment it has to
have very specific allegations and this
specific allegation occurred it was
sexual battery back in march 2010 or may
of 2010 and the charge was initially
filed
timely and it was within the statute of
limitations but since then the statute
has expired and in july the judge
dismissed it but gave the attorneys the
ability to replete and refile and they
did that and they did it this time and
it was very specific and it used the
words continuously charged so because
they replete with that specificity the
charge has now been accepted yeah it's
been added now definitely something that
i think the defense will have to tackle
and let's speak about that julie now
that weinstein is indicted on this
additional charge what do you think the
next move is for the defense
they've showed what their next move
which is basically to take some time
they want to review the charge they want
to see if they got it right this time
meaning did the prosecution get it right
because they got it right got it wrong
quite a few times already and so you
know the defense has been very effective
in making them go back in again and
again and i think that they're going to
potentially try it again if they're not
successful then this is going to be
potentially grounds for appeal if
if he is convicted of this specific
crime or or any of those crimes but
obviously time will tell all right so
review the grand jury minutes potential
appellate issues down the road seems
like a lot that the defense can work
with here as they progress in this case
in california uh julie just quickly do
you think there's an appellate issue
here do you think there's a good chance
or is it just one of many you got to try
you know i was listening to what donna
said and donna said you know you know
there's a point where you have to stop
but there's a victim here and the victim
is kind of
you know an important aspect of making
sure that justice is served and quite
frankly terry is right april was the
statute of limitations date and they
filed it in time the issue is what
happened afterwards so i think at the
end they're going to be successful
meaning the prosecution is going to be
successful as to whether they win at
trial is a whole other issue all right
we'll see how this plays out as it
continues of course we'll give you guys
a gavel coverage here when we come back
day eight on the stand for the real
estate heir accused of murder what
robert durst has to say about his affair
with prudence pharaoh and the best
friend he's accused of murdering next
[Music]
welcome back we head to california where
robert durst is on day four of
cross-examination facing more tough
questions about his alleged affair with
a woman who inspired one of the beatles
hit songs
the relay state air is on trial for the
murder of his best friend susan berman
who shot execution style in her home
near los angeles prosecutors say durst
killed berman because she knew exclusive
information about his wife's cathy
disappearance another murder that durst
is accused of george is under intense
cross-examination where prosecutor john
lewin asked him about his affair with
prudence pharaoh the defendant allegedly
made a phone call to pharaoh days before
his wife vanished
isn't it true you made a call from a pay
phone to prudence pharaoh a few days
before kathy disappeared
i don't recall
the telephone call
that prudence said i made
would you agree that during
your conversation with prudence that she
made clear to you that she was going to
quote cut you off
because she did not want to date you
while
you were married or not separated from
kathy
who
never said anything to me
about not wanting to see me
as long as i was married to kathy
in her interview
putin's pharaoh
changed her mind
repeatedly
about what our relationship was
the state continued to press duress
about his best friend and her ability to
tell stories alleging that if susan had
information about his wife it might slip
into the wrong hands
could susan have a big mouth
susan had a big mouth
your terminology is big mouth
not mine
okay what would your terminology be
she told
stories you agree that susan berman as
your best friend even though she was
someone you cared about and even though
she was somebody that was very loyal
that
if you had told her
a secret such as confessing to murder
that you would have been very concerned
about her ability to keep that quiet
anything
i said to susan
would be something that susan
might talk about
julie do you think lewin has caught
duras in that big got you moment yet or
do you think this cross is about the
little inconsistencies
it's a fair question i think it's a
little bit of both i mean any time you
get a defendant on the stand to refuse
to answer a question that's being asked
of you that's a gotcha moment now one
would argue that the reason he's not
asked answering questions at this point
is because he's had enough he's been up
there for i i mean most of my adult life
um so it's you know
in terms of that that could be the
reason but yes i think there's gotcha
moments and then there's so many
inconsistencies between the the you know
the jinx uh movie the the interviews um
and he's gotten caught in many many many
many lives whether they add up to him
murdering susan berman beyond a
reasonable doubt obviously that's for
the jury to decide
now tara i'm curious so the end of this
testimony do you think that durst
believed berman's loose lips could sink
his ship or was she a trusted confidant
of durst
listen i think it was a little bit of
both there's no question that he loved
susan berman he even said that susan was
closer to him than his family but at the
same time brian he did not trust her for
a minute and i think he started hearing
that she was talking about what he
confided in her and he was afraid that
she was going to go to the authorities
and so he protected himself and what he
had to do which is what he does all of
the time julie's talking about these
inconsistencies that's exactly what he
does he says what he needs to say when
he needs to say it all right we'll see
how this continues of course law and
crimes covering the case thank you for
joining us here at law on crime daily
we'll see you next time as you discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you